that's how you write a side ofy
song jny called me up on the phone last
night but something about the way she
said how your life and you think what
the hell is the point in
this we're just talking for the shake of
it walk past the corner
store think God I quit my job there real
life is sech up for I don't get what
they doing it
[Music]
for I go wrong too late to fix my
emotional I'm always SP
on my own and that's when the man on the
TV
said Cowboys don't have
[Music]
friends and never really cared about
getting it right but something about the
way I do over time made me think what
the hell am I doing this
for just to write a good metap
for did I go wrong to like to fix my
emotional I'm always been
on my own and that's what man on the TV
said Cowboys don't have
[Music]
friends
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
session uh if you'd like to grab a set
of the these pop and flow poy from flow
toys you can do so by using the promo
code drexfactor 32024 at checkout over
at flowtoys.com once again that is Drex
Factor
32024 thank you to flow toys for
sponsoring this video and hooking me up
with these amazing LED poy also big
thanks go out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks go to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro tire light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-b buus
friend of the channel That is Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission finally this video would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now if you
like the videos that I create and you
like to sign up to support me making
them you can do so over at
patreon.com Factor poo go check that out
please and thank you in the meantime if
you'd like to check out more of my flow
videos I will go ahead and leave a link
to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on YouTube make sure to
get out and flow yourselves today thanks
again for watching and I'll see you with
a new video real soon take care now
peace